علمنا قبل المباراة أنه
سيكون صعبًا ، لن يكون الأمر سهلاً
خاصةً أول 20 دقيقة عندما أتيحت لنا
الفرصة للتسجيل بالذرة ، نعم لقد
ذهبت ، إنه شعور رائع أن
تسجل في تلك اللعبة مثل
مساعدة  تأهل الفريق إلى الدور نصف النهائي ،
إنه شعور رائع
لأنني كنت أشعر بالبرد أمام المرمى ،
لقد فعلت ذلك بشكل جيد ، لذلك أنا سعيد
بذلك وأحبكم المشجعون ذهبوا إلى النهاية
حيث كان المشجعون المسافرون قادرون على ذلك.
تسمعهم ، نعم بالطبع في كل يوم من الألعاب تأتيهم
، لأن الأغنية
الخاصة بي ، لكني أحببتني أحببتهم
لأنني ألعب هنا غير ممتلئ ، أسمع
أن كل لعبة وأشعر بالحب
في المدينة في  النادي في التدريبات ،
لذا يمكنك أنت والفريق هنا الفوز
بدوري أبطال أوروبا هذا الموسم ، يمكننا أن
نكون في نهائي فردي ، أقول دائمًا إننا نأخذ
الأمر خطوة بخطوة لكننا في
نصف نهائي يمكن أن يحدث كل شيء ،
يذهب الجميع إلى المباراة في  نصف النهائي
أو ربع النهائي لأن لدينا
اقتراح  علينا أن نفوز ، يمكننا أن نفعل ذلك
الآن حتى آخر مباراتين سيم حتى الخطوة الأخيرة